andrew is in DC hey Andrew
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show yes I
Dave had a question to you about
investment real estate so my wife and I
we bought a new house in November of
2019 so just about eight months ago we
had really strong equity in that
previous home and so we decided to keep
on to it and to rent it out so since we
didn't sell it we could only put about a
hundred and sixty thousand down on our
new house if we had sold the old house
we would have profited around three
hundred eighty five thousand off of that
sale so therefore we had to do a 30-year
mortgage on the new house simply for
cash flow now the old house is going to
be paid off in about four or five years
and our plan was to take that rental
income and apply it to our new house to
pay down the house after additionally
soon I guess what I should say is we we
reworked our budget and we've got about
an extra two thousand per month we can
put down against our new home our
current home to pay it down but I was
wondering if we should start saving that
extra two thousand per month now and buy
another rental property maybe next year
because I know that real estate is such
a good investment so wanted to get your
perspective on that please well as we
have studied people who have a net worth
of one to five million dollars the data
tells us that one of the two things that
caused them to be able to achieve that
mathematically was their 401k in Roth
IRA and steadily investing the second
was that their personal residence is
paid for and so what that proves out
what we have said for decades around
here that the shortest distance between
where you sit today and becoming wealthy
is to avoid debt because that lowers
risk
and increases cash flow nothing in your
story parallels that idea yeah so you
know in other words you're probably not
going to do what we would suggest
certainly we would suggest no third
property absolutely not
and if I woke up in your shoes I'd sell
the rental and pay off my house as fast
as I could and then I'd save up and buy
some rentals I think you got in a hurry
okay yeah I mean we had worked with our
previous our real estate it was an ELP
and she had suggested we keep onto the
old property because it would be a good
investment yeah most real estate I don't
believe that whether they're LPS or not
but that doesn't mean they're not wrong
so I mean you can do whatever you want
to do I don't care just because one of
our LPS gave you the wrong advice
doesn't mean that our advice is going to
change and but the logic for my advice
is real simple that the the piece and
the lowered risk and the increased cash
flow that having your home paid off does
is it allows you to move on to other
investments with cash rather than yeah I
got little dad over here got all that
over here a little more dad over on the
third property now and and I got $2,000
a month and then and you just you're
just bifurcating all your efforts you're
spreading them out all over the place
mathematically and so that nothing tends
to pile up because there's no laser
focus this is what the borrower is slave
to the lender means it's back to what we
were talking when I think even the first
segment of the show of it's not always
the math thing right like that there you
go that is a mething but that's what I'm
saying that we get the math makes sense
but when you look at it to be able to
just say hey you just kind of a paid-for
house even though you're like well wow
there's a lot of equity here we could
keep it make some good rental like right
like the math of all of what he's saying
though it you don't stand it because we
don't risk his map doesn't is leaving
out risk right that's always like when
you plug in risk yeah the the benefits
of leverage go away and so this idea
that there's good debt is just absurd
and I'd you know
you know truthfully I've we've lived our
lives for 30 years and Rachel and
Winston live their lives that way and
you know all the Ramsey kids and is we
avoid that and that enables us to have
all of our income to build up for other
investments and other dreams and other
things we can do where we're not
supporting some stinking Bank and the
the great lie of America is that banks
have told us for generations that the
way to have your best life is do
business with us the way to have your
best life is to get your credit card out
the way to have your best life is take
out a home equity loan to go on that
cruise oops there's a kovat you know and
then you got a problem
and so it's a you know there's always
that oops and so again you do whatever
you want to do obviously you're not
doing like you're not on the edge of
bankruptcy or something but you're not
taking what I know to be the shortest
path between where you are and wealth it
feels like it's the shortest path
because you own this stuff but you don't
really own any of it because you're in
debt on it and so we highly recommend
you go a more conservative slower
approach and you will end up at the end
of the story with more money but it's
very frustrating and it's
countercultural and you know a lot of
people don't believe it but most people
are broke so I don't really care what
they think about in the risk aspect you
know even you saying you know spreading
it out here that property this bar that
you just slowly start to build this
house of cards and then yeah
pandemic hits I mean who knows life
happens and suddenly if your income
stops and that renter who was in that
property now can't pay their rent well
you're out that cash flow that was
helping you cash flow your regular
mortgage and it all just starts to
crumble down really quickly and so that
risk is a key part to this story and
when you have no debt there is no risk